[Music]
I never emotionally lost my
[Music]
take one so would you be okay to answer
a couple questions so would you be down
to answer like a couple of questions
what's the most painful thing someone is
said to you who's one stranger useful
remembers do I have any talents first of
all be kind of easy can you just tell us
a little bit about yourself so what's
like your what's your dream what do you
want to do man
mechanical engineering okay I can sounds
like you're on the right track yeah
who's one stranger you still remember
this could be someone you met once years
ago or like someone who ended up being a
friend but that first impact like has
really stuck with you when you said that
the first thing that came to mind was
when I went camping and there was this
through these two kids on bikes that
started bullying me and they just rolled
their bikes around in there every time I
came by they'd like just like you guys
my cousins and they're like sure we
became really good friends so you
basically turned your boys of your
friends exactly they were obviously
hurting your feelings right what made
you want to like reach out to them and
ask them if they wanted to play with you
[Music]
things just don't get to me hey you guys
want to play some manhunt we're just
like yeah sure okay who's one stranger
you still remember I remember I was in
eighth grade and I just really miss
school crying every day before classes
start people start laughing at me I kept
seeing myself
no the problem is they're saying they
don't say that we need their armor on
March 1 times like this
lovely whatever you want your life to be
it could be if you want to be silent and
besides you want to be happy if you're
gonna tell yourself saying you'll be
happy everything gonna be happy and I
guess I was the only thing I had the
last it just taught me because I tried
everything so I tried it and it was
awesome what's the most painful thing
someone has said to you but it was like
you'll never be nothing you'll never be
successful like what like what they say
so do you have advice for other people
who maybe have heard the same words but
unlike you they kind of let it get them
down a peg like this boss but you don't
don't take those words don't run with it
because if you keep everything
hello I'm good are you I don't I wish
you understand everything I'm saying no
right no so do you want to try to talk
or do you want to skip I'm a youtuber is
it okay with you that I'm recording yeah
you are youtuber - are you recording
this
[Music]
you are do I have any talents I could
clap with one hand pick one hand no no
that's my talent that's my talent my
talent I clap with one hand that's my
talent and then also have you seen this
have you seen this trick this one how
you thank you for your time as well I
wish my your English is better than my
Spanish so alright thank you bye is
there like an interesting fact like a
unique fact about you that most people
don't know that I have
singing voice okay you have a good
singing voice why doesn't anyone know
about it you just are you just too shy
to like maybe tell people oh yeah yeah
would you be down to sing right now you
tell me something you think any song you
know right now
just ditch down anything it's so good if
I have a good voice I'd be singing all
the time
what's the most painful thing someone
has said to you has called me I felt
before or what sucked out of everything
painful that you've ever heard why do
you think that one hurts you the most
because I don't think that's true I've
been trying to find someone great to
have a relationship with for like a few
years but it never worked out so because
of that people like to call me that
not many people but it's not nice you
know because I was trying to find
happiness not they caught the cold thud
who's one stranger you store remember
what's the most painful thing you've
been told been told
yeah probably when my ex well by now ex
when we were dating at the time so I can
go to my car real quick people are
bringing it home like yeah sure and then
she started crying and then she was like
I'm sorry to say this but we need a
breakup
I never emotionally lost my because I
loved her and I never expected us to
ever break up because we all like she
always told me and I've always said it
back back we're not gonna break up like
we're forever
we're gym for two years it's nice
meeting you thanks for answering my
questions
[Music]
what's your name on YouTube okay here is
my name No
I'm sorry god no you're okay so if I put
up this video I'll include your YouTube
channel so thank you I'm gonna subscribe
to you to hang on let me what's your
YouTube channel I do yeah I just got it
it is yeah do you want one but you have
to ask your parents first you can't we
can't do it without your parents
permission
okay okay
oh god no okay how do we skip
he told my red I'm sweaty
why am i wearing sweater okay um how
does it get on my goal